Mike it's another unboxing video Rob it
looks like uncharted 4 it does and it is
the Liberty Lea collector's edition cool
let's open it up
sweet you do the honors alright here we
go you can see it's got coin on there I
know what that is that logo I don't know
if I'm gonna get any spoilers and
probably notice maybe in the game okay
we'll go like this way it looks like
that's what it's here boom boom let's
start with probably the coolest part
yeah the steelbook case with a bunch of
characters on it of course you have
Nathan Drake Victor Sullivan nope Victor
Sullivan Sam Drake Nathan's brother who
comes back and you know Elena's right
here other character we won't get into
because it might spoil it but anyway of
course you haven't
it's a nice finish yeah and a bunch of
soldiers the backi of a what looks to be
a dead person and just bones but anyway
of course the game oh and someone else
in there yeah you have a bunch of
stickers so the artbook nice which you
know they have like big uncharted
one-two-three art books but here you
have here specifically for character art
for no prisoners right there do soldiers
new areas in the game you got characters
oh man don't show that one yeah Nathan
Drake himself in his uncharted 4 garb
the statue and a little bit of a
tropical jungle plant down here oh it's
not real fake no you might want to water
in case you never know you never know
like a whole string is pistol or on
whole string it no and Drake probably
the ladder okay and that's pretty much
it actually which it however I think you
know stuff you can't really show off
where's that other box comes with three
skins for the multiplayer I believe
mm-hmm Oh Drake Drake specific skins
right some weapon skins skins got an
ak-47 in a pistol there mm-hmm
a hat and some other sidekick outfits
and three
to spend on uncharted points yeah and
there you have it that is our unboxing
video of the uncharted 4 collector's
edition you reviewed the game yeah the
game comes out May 10th and if you want
to go that extra mile you go ahead and
you get this collector's edition yeah
cool well thanks very much Mike thank
you rob